that's a big problem because restaurants
tend to put things in that make food
taste better and food to taste it
usually is somewhat fatty a lot of
places have the calorie counts of foods
and the protein etc contents avoiding
fried things steamed etc using sauces
not heavy sauces and not so liberally to
take food thats a high protein not
flavored with fats and oils and putting
some some small amount of flavorful
sauce on it that's not fat based
unfortunately a lot of cream sauces and
things like that butter comes along with
cooking so you know picking the right
foods vegetables steamed not buried in
in lots of cream sauce fish meats etc
that are relatively lean and being
careful with the carbohydrates that you
pick that the bread on the table
probably something to stay away from but
the wild rice on the menu probably okay
the mashed potatoes maybe not as good as
you know the sweet potatoes or like I
say higher glycemic index so picking the
right types of foods educating yourself
about what and then asking questions
about how things will come I think
healthy means well-balanced to some
degree I think you can do vegetarian or
vegan well as long as you know what
you're doing and you're careful about it
you can get all the protein sources and
vitamins sources you need from the right
combination of vegetarian materials
absolutely it's hard to be pure vegan
and getting the right protein mix unless
you really know what you're doing so if
you're gonna stay away from fish eggs
meats cheeses milks you got to be really
careful with your balance of of nuts and
beans and corn and rice and things like
that to get the right protein mix in
because there are certain amino acids
that the body can't produce but that are
necessary and you don't get those in it
won't be healthy the right amounts of
facts can also be gotten from
the vegan diet is only picture life